[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRETT HESTERBERG:
Today we're going
to be joined by Peter Bakkum.
Peter is the platform
lead at Quizlet.
And the two of us
are going to be
talking about running
open-source databases on Google
Cloud Platform.
So a few goals for today.
We'll take a look
at what we view
as some of the most popular
open-source databases
in the market right
now, and we'll
look at how you go about running
those databases on Google Cloud
Platform.
We'll take a look at
what Google offers,
what some of our partners
offer with respect to managed
services, and we'll
look at how you can
self-manage these databases.
And then Peter
will join onstage,
and he'll talk about lessons
learned by Quizlet with respect
to running MySQL on
Google Cloud Platform.
Quizlet generally has a really
impressive MySQL architecture,
and I know I'm
excited that he's here
to share some of their
learnings through, I think,
some pain and
certainly some success,
as well, running MySQL
on Google Cloud Platform.
So before I jump in, let me just
ask a question to all of you.
By a show of hands,
how many developers
do we have in the audience?
OK.
So about a little more than
half the room, maybe even 2/3.
How many database administrators
do we have in the room?
A few.
How many reluctant
database administrators
do we have in the room?
There's a few more.
[LAUGHS] And how many managers
do we have in the room?
We got a handful.
OK.
Great.
Well, I hope the
presentation will
have something for everyone,
and, indeed, I think it will.
So let's get started here.
We'll take a look at
popular databases,
and we're going to start with
the analyst view of the world.
This is an analyst's view
of the database market,
as measured by revenue
or by market share.
The bars you see on this
slide are not to scale.
If you look leftmost, we
have our database market
at just over $35 billion.
And we compare that to
the open-source database
market and the NoSQL markets
at 300 and change million.
So if we actually
represented those
at scale, or in relative scale,
those would be, like, a pixel,
and you wouldn't be able to
pick up the numbers there.
The take on this, at
least from my perspective,
is that the analysts
are measuring a market
in a very rational way.
They're looking at dollars
spent, or money spent,
on databases, usually in the
form of database licenses
and also in support contracts
and associated services.
Historically, this has very much
benefited commercial databases
that often come with
large license fees.
I think the reports
like this tend
to understate the significance
of open-source databases
in business, and this is
starting to change now.
This view of the
world is starting
to change in that cloud
vendors like Google, some
of our partners,
other cloud vendors,
are offering database services
based on open-source databases.
And they're finding significant
interest from customers,
and that's generating revenue.
So these bars are starting
to change over time.
I honestly think
what we have here is
kind of a massive shadow market,
where, if you surveyed everyone
running an open-source
database, you've
got a very large number of
users depending day to day
on open-source databases.
And it's not reflected in
these type of reports yet.
OK, with that in mind, we're
talking about the smaller
segments on this chart, our
open-source database charts.
We, Google, have a very
casual relationship
with a company
called DB-Engines.
DB-Engines looks at signals.
Things like job postings,
development activity,
and a number of other
signals to determine
how popular, relatively, are
databases one to another.
What we're showing here
is a list of databases.
You can see rightmost
column, we've
highlighted relational databases
like MySQL, and Postgres,
for example, along with MariaDB.
We've highlighted some of
the NoSQL databases, Mongo,
and some new SQL databases,
Cassandra, Redis,
Elasticsearch, HBase.
And what you see is kind
of a relative popularity.
Note that the y-axis
here is in log scale.
So you have MySQL
at the top, kind
of the most popular
open-source database,
at least as measured
by database engines.
And you see some
others that are growing
in popularity over time.
Now given the log scale, you've
got something starting down
on the y-axis at 2, while
MySQL is above 1,000,
so bear that in mind.
What we've seen in
the relational space,
very steady growth in terms
of popularity for a database
engine like PostgreSQL.
And you can see a
number of the others
that I've highlighted
here growing
in popularity over time.
What we'll look at
as we go forward
are these databases,
what options Google
has for you with
respect to these
databases in Google Cloud,
what options our partners bring
in terms of managed
services, and how you can get
started self-managing
one of these databases.
And what I'll note here is as
a product manager for Cloud
SQL, which is a managed
database service,
I certainly have a bias.
I love managed
database services.
But I think what it comes down
to in terms of selecting--
do I self-manage a database,
do I go to a managed database
service--
is really the trade-off between
customization and that time
and toil in management.
When I think about
looking at a database
service versus
self-managing, I think
you all are aware of the
trade-offs you're making day
to day with your time.
As developers, as DBAs, as
managers, you are deciding,
I am going to customize this
part of my technology stack.
And I'm willing
to spend the time
to maintain that
part of the stack.
Other parts of the
stack you may say,
I'd like to turn this over to
someone else, and, in doing so,
I'm going to give up some
of the customization I
can get by managing it myself.
I think that's the
trade-off you look at.
So as we go through
these options,
hopefully they simply
illuminate some
of the options you have with
respect to these databases
on Google Cloud.
And then Peter
will join onstage,
and Peter will take you through
their rationale, Quizlet's
rationale, for
self-managing MySQL and some
of the experiences they've
had on Google Cloud Platform.
So let's start with
MySQL and MariaDB,
which some will
call it MySQL clone,
certainly a fork of MySQL.
For the Google-offered
service here,
Cloud SQL, our managed
relational database service,
has for years offered MySQL.
Cloud SQL, we say,
is compatibility.
But more than
compatibility-- we are
more than just a compatibility
layer, I should say.
We are offering standard
MySQL databases,
and Cloud SQL takes care of
often mundane maintenance
operations.
Things like patching
the database,
patching the underlying
operating system,
making replication feel
easy or click a button.
We monitor high
availability, for example,
and you're backed by
Google's team with respect
to high availability.
So it goes beyond
just the tooling
to make sure that a database
is up, and if it's not,
that we're failing over.
You're getting
someone, in the end,
looking at these systems 24 by
7 so that you don't have to.
That's kind of the essence of
the managed database service.
What I will note about Cloud
SQL is that it is not a DBA.
The hope with Cloud SQL is that,
for developers, it offers you
a chance to develop, to focus
more on your development,
rather than on
database management.
For DBAs, I hope
it allows DBAs who
choose to use Cloud SQL
a chance to do something
a bit more higher
value with their time
than installing or
provisioning a database,
or patching a
database, for example.
We have a partner in ClearDB
offering managed services
in this very space, as well.
And we have, we note, in
our launcher platform,
which is pre-built
images or OS images that
include an installation of
MySQL or Percona or other MySQL
relational databases.
We have those options for you.
So as you move down
this chart, you'll
see this again and again
as I go through these,
we have Google's managed
service, a partner's managed
service, and options
for you to quickly
get started self-hosting
these databases.
Taking a look at Postgres.
Cloud SQL, as of yesterday
at this conference,
announced support for the
first time for PostgreSQL.
It was a longstanding
request, and we're
very happy to be saying
yes to that request now.
So Cloud SQL for Postrgres
just went beta as of yesterday,
is launching right now.
We have ElephantDB, who
is running a managed
service as a partner.
And you see in the launcher
space here offerings
from EnterpriseDB,
strong Postgres partner;
from Aiven, who is offering
a managed service as well;
and we have Bitnami
images, which,
effectively, package a Postrgres
installation into an image.
So you can quickly get
started with Postgres.
One thing to note on the
DB-Engines ranking here,
you see the rise in
Postgres over time.
I think the momentum
behind Postgres
right now is really exciting.
It has a long history
of active development,
and we're excited,
as Google, now
to have an offering in
the managed space here.
Taking a look at
Cassandra and HBase.
Google has a product
called Bigtable, which
I hope you've all heard of.
It has an HBase API layer.
So when we talk about
HBase at Google,
we refer to Bigtable as
our product in this space.
In terms of managed
service offerings,
our partner, Instaclustr, has
offerings around the Cassandra
space.
And then, of course, we have
launcher images, both Cassandra
proper, as well as
from DataStax, to help
get you started with Cassandra.
And you can see some interesting
movement in the Cassandra
and HBase rankings in the
DB-Engines chart to the right.
Looking at MongoDB,
Cloud Datastore's
our offering in this space.
Datastore is often
paired with App Engine,
for those of you who
are familiar with it.
But Datastore is
great when it comes
to big scale and,
especially, document storage.
Looking at managed
service offerings,
Mongo Labs has an offering, as
well as Compose and MongoDB.
In the launcher space, again,
we have standard Mongo options
and MongoDB with
replication to help
you get going rapidly with
MongoDB on the Google Cloud
Platform.
And looking now at Redis.
We've recently unveiled
App Engine Memcache.
I think you will continue to
see us innovate in this space.
We think in-memory databases
are important and caching
layer's important there.
The managed service
offerings we have
are via partnerships with Redis
Labs and again with Aiven.
And we've got some
representation from Aiven,
I think, in the audience
potentially today, as well.
Looking at our
launcher space, we've
got classic Redis as one of
our launcher applications.
If you haven't been to
Cloud Launcher, take a look.
We see customers getting
some value out of Launcher
even just for simple
things like testing.
And then those images can
certainly end up in production.
But it's just a quick
way to get started
with some of these
applications on Google Cloud.
So I'm very happy to
now be introducing
Peter Bakkum from Quizlet.
Peter's the platform
lead, and Quizlet
is a heavy user of
MySQL, and generally,
a heavy user of the
Google Cloud Platform.
So Peter, I think, has
a great story to tell
and hopefully some
lessons learned
that you can all benefit
from with respect to running
MySQL on Google Cloud Platform.
So please join me
in welcoming Peter.
[APPLAUSE]
PETER BAKKUM: Thanks.
Everybody, I'm Peter.
I work on platform at Quizlet.
And I'm really excited
to be here today.
I think to preface this,
there's an implication
if I'm standing
up here that we've
solved all these
problems, and we
have this perfect,
great infrastructure
that never goes down.
And I definitely
don't feel that way.
But I think the
value in these talks
is just for us to give
you information about how
we run our infrastructure,
and hopefully, my goal
is you'll come away from this
with just a few more ideas
and some context of what we do.
And hopefully that
would help you
if you're running
something similar.
So that's my goal here.
I'm going to give you
a bunch of information
about our architecture, some
decisions we've made, how we
can figure things, et cetera.
And hopefully it'll be useful.
And there's going to be
questions at the end.
If you don't get
your question in,
I'll be around, as well,
just to chat about it,
if you're interested
in doing that.
So I'd like to start with just
a brief introduction to Quizlet,
if you haven't heard of us.
Quizlet is an ed tech company.
We make a study tool that
you plug your content into,
and then it helps you practice
and master that content.
So we've had really strong
adoption in high schools,
colleges, things like that.
It's really good for vocabulary,
foreign language, et cetera.
We have web and
mobile native apps.
And some stats on us.
We have about 25
million users a month,
and on Quantcast, we're
like a top 25 US website.
So we've grown from
something pretty small
into something that's having
a major impact on education.
So this has been our
growth curve over time.
So we're really lucky to
have strong organic growth.
But the things I want
to point out here
is this is a challenging
domain to run databases in.
So you can see we're
an education company.
It's very, very seasonal.
So no one studies over
the summer, it turns out.
It's pretty quiet.
So we get this big
drop off in the summer,
and then every year
in August, September
we hit back to school
when US students return
to high schools, universities,
and we get this big jump.
So that's also where
our growth hits.
So summer is-- we really
focus on load testing,
preparing for that rush,
and effectively, we
are preparing for
a level of traffic
that we've never really seen.
So this is difficult. We get
these big seasonal swings
of traffic, and we need to
manage and deal with this.
It's really important that
we stay up and stable.
If we go down, this
is what happens.
This is a tweet of a classroom.
All the students are
holding iPads that
say Quizlet is down on them.
And actually, the projector
in the back says that as well.
And so I put this up
here just to empathize
with the user a little
bit and underline
why we feel this
is important to us
and why we care
about running this
really stably and performantly.
And avoiding this
kind of situation,
which is hard to see
when this happens, right?
So that's why we're here.
Like many applications,
Quizlet started pretty simple.
It was our founder,
Andrew, wrote it to help
himself study in high school.
And when we started,
it was pretty simple.
It was just an application in
a database, written in PHP,
communicating with MySQL.
And as we've grown, as
we've hit that growth
curve over the past 10 years,
we've had to scale this up.
We've had to re-architect and
solve this scaling challenge.
So what have we done?
So this may be a pretty
familiar list to a lot of you.
We've done the basic
stuff-- we've added indexes,
we've optimized our queries.
We've done things like
eliminating joins,
so our queries almost
always hit a single table.
We've moved to bigger
hardware, so we've just
scaled up vertically.
And we started
caching query results.
I'm going to talk a little
bit how we use Memcached.
We've moved to partition tables.
So we've taken a
single table, and we've
used MySQL partitioning
to split that
into multiple individual
files on disk.
We've compressed table data.
This helps with Disk I/O.
And probably our
biggest scaling effort
has been around taking
tables and splitting them out
into their own hardware.
So this is just
vertical sharding.
So our biggest tables we
run on separate instances.
Once you do this, you have
a more complex architecture,
but you get much,
much more scale.
Because we use
replication, we've
started running queries
on replica sets.
So these are the queries
that don't necessarily
need to be exactly consistent.
So if you do a write
and you do a read,
they don't necessarily need
to be completely up to date.
But this is a really
nice scaling strategy.
And once you do
this, you can then
increase the number of
replicas and scale this way.
So this has been our strategy.
As I said, I'm sure
that some of you
are probably familiar with this
and have done similar things.
And I want to talk a little bit
about the implications of this
on our architecture
and what this actually
looks like to run on GCP.
So here's our
current architecture.
This is just a very
high-level diagram.
We have the web app.
It's talking to these pods
of master replica pairs.
We run the replicas so that
we can swap between when
we need to do maintenance.
Or if there's a production
issue on the master,
we're able to failover and
promote the replica to a master
and run that way.
The important part is the
replica is always there,
and it's always ready
if we need to swap over.
We would run a separate
replica for backups.
And we snap shot this
replica, and I'll explain
a little bit more about that.
As I mentioned before,
we've taken tables,
and we've split them
into their own hardware.
So we now run a production,
eight of these pods
of master replica pairs.
And in some of these pods,
like in the middle here,
we run multiple replicas.
So we've scaled in that way.
And then finally, we run
this tier of caching.
And the application
communicates with this pool
of Memcached machines,
and this alleviates
some of the load on MySQL.
I'll talk a little
bit more about that.
So what does our
workload look like?
As I mentioned, we've split
out into separate pods.
We have about 3 terabytes
of production data,
and if you add in the indexes,
that's another 2.2 terabytes.
So I think of this as kind
of a medium-sized workload.
There's many MySQL
workloads that
are much, much larger than
this, but this is basically
the domain we've scaled into.
During an average
week, we peak around
28,000 queries per
second, and that's
spread across all
of our databases,
across all of the replicas.
And in total, we have
about 40 billion rows,
and that's across 100 tables.
So whenever we add a feature
or something like that,
we often end up with
an additional table,
and so the app is communicating
with about 100 tables in total.
So this is the shape
of the workload.
And there's a bunch
of entities in there.
That 40 billion rows,
it's both the content--
so at Quizlet our content is
term and definition pairs.
That's what people are studying.
But it's also some
more analytical things.
So we record every answer that
anyone punches into Quizlet,
and we can use this to
help people study later on.
So this is important
data, and it's important
that it's in the production
database rather than just
an analytical database so we
can use it in the application
and help drive
studying later on.
So this is our traffic
during an average week.
I think this is pretty
common with a lot
of consumer-facing companies,
but this is starting Saturday.
So you can see, not much
studying on Saturday.
Sunday night we start
seeing this hump.
And then during the week,
we see a bunch of traffic
in the morning-- this is
when people are using Quizlet
in school and the
classroom-- and then
we see another hump at night.
And so this is when
people are studying
at night for the next day.
So you'll notice that we don't
see that evening hump on Friday
night.
So I think one question
that I would have
is, why are you guys doing this?
Why aren't you
running Cloud SQL?
It's the managed service.
It would solve a lot
of these problems.
So my philosophy on this is
you should use managed services
whenever and wherever
you can, and they
have a huge, huge
potential to save you time,
save you money, save you
operational costs, et cetera.
We moved over to GCP a couple
of years ago, and at the time
we needed larger machines
than Cloud SQL offered.
And we've continued to
scale up to larger machines,
and so we're now
running on 64 core VMs.
We'd also had
operational experience
running MySQL on
our previous cloud,
and so we had a
relationship with Percona,
and we've tuned our
databases specifically
for our workload with Percona.
So some of the configurations
was specific to us,
and we wanted to continue
having control over those.
We also had experience managing
the replication and failover.
And we like to control
that, because we know where
you are in the recovery step and
what the replication is doing
and being able to handle
that kind of promotion
and that kind of thing.
There's a maintenance cost
there and complexity costs,
but we wanted to be able
to handle that ourselves.
But as I said, we're
very, very optimistic
about hosted infrastructure,
and we use it wherever we can.
And we'll likely revisit how
we run this stuff over time.
So how have we configured this?
What does this looks like?
So we run Percona MySQL 5.7.
This is a recent
Percona release.
And as I said, we run a bunch
of different machine sizes.
So the smaller machines are the
backup machines, our 8 core,
they're the standard-8's.
And this scales up
to 64-core machines.
So we're using the
highmem-64 cores, which
are about 400 gigs of memory.
And those are where
we need the most power
and we have the biggest
database workloads.
We're using the Google,
just vanilla PD-SSD drives,
so this is 25,000 IOPS.
And so we've
optimized our workload
around that ceiling
and that number,
and it's important to us.
We're also using
GTID-based replication.
So the thing to know
about that, if you're not
familiar with that,
GTID replication
is a way of tracking
the transactions that
have been sent to a replica
and then executed on a replica.
And they're important because
if you have two databases that
have the same GTID
executions, then
you can be pretty sure that they
have the same database state.
So it's a really convenient
way of managing this,
and when we're
swapping in replicas,
we ensure that there's
GTID consistency there.
So I just wanted
to call that out
as an important piece of this.
We've done a number of
things to tune the workload.
And the things that I want to
highlight there are the biggest
configuration changes we've made
from a performance standpoint
have been to tune the buffer
pool sizes and optimize this,
and tune the number
of buffer pools.
So buffer pools,
as you may know,
it's how MySQL is
caching pages in memory.
So it's a MySQL-managed
cache, and we
tune this to be around 80% of
the memory on these machines.
When you're running
[? machines ?]
with a number of cores--
so 64 cores you're
going to end up
with a number of worker
threads, and the buffer pools
are a shared resource.
And so if you don't scale
the number of buffer pools
with the number of CPU cores,
you end up with contention.
So we found it very
important for our performance
to optimize a number of
buffer pool instances.
And the current number
we use is two CPU cores
to a buffer pool instance.
Though we may experiment
more with that.
So next I want to talk about
how we access this from the app.
So what does it look like on
the ground when the Quizlet
app actually talks to MySQL?
So Quizlet was originally
written in PHP.
It was originally just
a PHP MySQL application.
I think a lot of
apps start this way.
PHP is not the favorite
language of many people.
And so what we've done
is try to optimize how we
use it, improve how we use it.
And the state we're
in now is we're
using HHVM, which is Facebook's
PHP just-in-time compiler.
It carries a number
of advantages.
We were able to significantly
reduce our machine footprint.
We cut our number of web
servers by about half
by switching to HHVM.
And it also introduces a
layer of type information.
So if you're just
running vanilla PHP,
HHVM attempts to detect
the types you're using
and optimize based on that.
We've also begun using a
language called Hack, which
is based on HHVM, and it
carries a number of features,
but at its simplest,
it's like a typed PHP.
So we've transitioned a
lot of our code into Hack,
and this has had
a lot of benefits,
and the application developers
are pretty happy about this.
So application running in HHVM,
we're communicating with MySQL
via HHVM PDO, which is an
extension written in C++ that
handles details of connections,
queries, et cetera,
and communicates
directly with MySQL.
So all of our queries are
going through HHVM PDO.
Finally, moving a layer up,
we're running custom ORM.
So within our application,
this big HHVM application,
queries are going
through this ORM.
As you can see, I've included
a sample query at the bottom
here.
This is a fluent interface we
have for composing queries.
You can do things like add query
predicates, filters, et cetera.
You can mark a query
as read scalable, which
means it's OK to
send to the replica,
and it doesn't need consistency.
And then this is going
to handle the actual
composing the SQL query and
sending the results back.
So this is how we're
actually forming the query,
communicating back
to the application.
This is what our developers
are interacting with.
So I want to talk about
caching for a second.
This, I think, is an
interesting piece of this puzzle
because caching gets
a little tricky.
I want to explain why.
We run a pool of
Memcached machines.
I think this is a pretty
standard architecture.
We do consistent
hashing, so each node,
each web node is communicating
with each of the Memcached
nodes.
And we're hashing
consistently, so each key
from all the web nodes ends
up on the same Memcached node.
So we're basically utilizing
Memcached as a cache for MySQL.
The advantage here is
we reduce query load,
so we're sending fewer
queries to MySQL,
but we're also, because
we're storing this in cache,
we are freeing up a lot of the
MySQL cache for other queries.
So things that would have
been going in the buffer pool,
increasing buffer pool
turnover, et cetera,
are instead just
going to Memcached.
So this is great,
but this gets tricky.
Remember, there's
really only one source
of truth for our data.
So MySQL is a source
The whole thing rests on MySQL.
It's our transactional,
relational database.
And fundamentally, if
we do a transaction,
if it fails to
write to Memcached,
the transaction still succeeds,
but Memcached is out of sync.
So this is
particularly important
because we're using
Memcached as a model cache.
So literally, our models
in the application,
we're serializing
those, and we're
storing those in Memcached.
And so when those get
out of sync, you can see,
you immediately
have inconsistency
in the application.
So we mitigate this partially
by setting a TTL on everything
we write to Memcached.
So effectively,
when this happens,
there's a limit on the
inconsistency you could see.
But it's important to
keep this in mind--
there's the possibility
of inconsistency.
For example, if there's
a network disruption,
you'd see this.
And certain things you don't
want in this framework.
So, for example, queries
around billing, right?
You don't want that to happen.
That's really, really critical.
So we utilize caching,
I think, pragmatically.
We think it's really beneficial
to reduce the load on MySQL.
But it's really important
to keep this in mind
when we're using it.
And we've played
around a lot with this
about where do we
set the TTL, where do
we bust the cache, et cetera.
There's another
layer of complexity
here, that if you re-balance
the cache buckets,
and then you re-balance
again, you also
have the chance of stale data.
So we've spent a
lot of time thinking
about this, about how we
manage the cache pool.
And just attempting
to be thoughtful
and avoid this situation.
What I'm getting at is,
basically, if a Memcached
node drops, what do you do?
One perspective, maybe,
you re-balance your cache,
but if this is
flapping, you can end up
with a lot of stale data.
So we actually never re-balance
the cache when we use it.
So next I want to talk
about our database failover
infrastructure.
What I mean by this
is we frequently
need to failover from
a master to a replica
and promote the replica
to the new master.
This is tricky because
fundamentally you
need to ensure data
consistency, and you
want to do this while you're
running the application.
You want to reduce downtime.
You want to reduce the
problems you're seeing.
So here's how we handle this.
We're doing service
discovery with Consul.
And the way this
works is Consul holds
the master and the
replica, holds the IPs,
and then we're templating
files from Consul.
So this means we're able to
change the value in consul,
and then this templates the
value into config files on all
of our application servers.
And this happens
really, really quickly.
So that's how we do
the service discovery,
but the application
still needs to be
aware of which is
the master when,
and we need to ensure
that there is consistency
when we do this failover.
This is a little bit tricky.
So here's our process for this.
We kickoff this process,
we pick a replica.
We know we want to swap
over to this replica,
promote it to the master.
And the first step is
to snapshot the replica.
So this will come
in useful later
on when we restart replication.
So we snapshot the
replica, we then
lock writes on
this whole system.
So on the database
we're switching,
we stopped doing
writes, and this
is because we need to wait
for the replica to catch up.
We need to wait
for the failover.
So we lock writes.
This is critical because this
has a major impact on the app.
The database that you're
doing this failover on,
you're then effectively
not serving that to users.
So this has a major impact on
how the application is running.
So we lock writes, and then
we wait for the replication
to catch up on the new master.
We're waiting.
In practice, our
replicas are often
within a second of the master
in terms of transactions.
But we want to be really extra
sure that they're caught up,
because if you don't wait
for replication to catch up,
you're effectively
leaving writes behind when
you swap to the new master.
So we wait for
replication to come up.
We promote the replica
to the new master.
So this is where
Consul comes in.
This is where we change
the service discovery,
we're templating the files on
all the application servers,
and then they know that,
OK, this is now the master.
We then unlock this database.
So this is the point
of no return, right?
This means we are both
writing to the new master
and reading from it.
And so this is the
point of no return,
because you then can't go
back to the previous master
without losing writes.
So this is a critical
piece of this.
So we've unlocked, the
application comes back,
we're reading and writing.
And then the next
step we need to do
is to restart replication
the other way.
So in other words,
the old master
now needs to replicate
from the new master.
This isn't strictly
necessary, but what
we do to avoid replication
problems is that we then
restore the snapshot
from the old replica,
put that on the new replica,
so we ensure there's complete
consistency, the
GTIDs match exactly,
and then we restart replication.
So now we're running fine,
we're running smoothly,
we're back in action.
This actually gets
even more complex
with multi-replica pools.
So as you can
imagine, you then need
to pick one of the
replicas to failover to.
And any other replicas then
need to be aware of this process
and point to the new one.
So as I mentioned
before, there's
a lot of complexity
in managing this.
We have experience
with this, and we
have scripting around this.
But with complexity, the
scripting is difficult to test,
because to test it
really thoroughly,
you need a very robust
staging or integration testing
environment.
The point I'd like to make is
just that there's complexity.
We manage it, because we
like having control of it,
we like knowing exactly
the characteristics of when
the failover is happening,
and being able to fix it
if something breaks.
But there's a cost to it.
So next I want to
talk about something
that's super important to us.
This is backups.
So we're replicating
data to another replica,
which is smaller.
And the purpose of
this machine is just
to keep up with the
write load and keep us
a state with the master,
so in other words,
follow closely
behind the master.
We're not reading
from this note at all.
This is one of my
favorite parts of GCP.
This is one of the
things we liked most
when we were evaluating GCP
as a potential platform.
The GCP snapshots
are very, very quick.
So even multi-terabyte
SSD drives,
we can snapshot those literally
in a matter of minutes.
This is pretty
significant, because what
it means is you can get a full
copy of a disk, consistent,
it's really, really
quick, and it's
fast enough that we're able
to do this once an hour.
So if we were to lose the
running instances we have,
the most data that we
would lose in that scenario
is an hour's worth of data.
So this is pretty nice.
We just press a snapshot
button, it goes, it saves,
and we have this guarantee.
So there's some
other things we want
to do in this infrastructure.
So one is we want to
test these backups.
We want to make sure
that they're consistent,
they're sane, if we need them
we can bring them back in.
And we also want to store
some copies of this elsewhere.
So we want to store
copies in the event
that we would lose access to
GCE, what if we lost access
to our entire GCP
account, et cetera?
We want to solve
that problem as well.
So this is what our
architecture looks like.
As I mentioned, we have
this backup replica.
This has an SSD that
we're snapshotting.
And then we do a couple
of things with this drive.
We take the snapshot,
we turn it into a disk,
and then we mount it
on two other machines.
So first is a backup tester.
All this machine does is it
looks for an untested backup.
It brings it in, it
mounts the drive,
and it does the MySQL recovery.
So once the MySQL
recovery is done,
you can run queries on this.
And we just run a
pretty simple query.
So we're making sure
the data is sane,
the tables are as
large as we expect,
we're seeing recent time stamps
on the tables, et cetera.
The worst case scenario here
is you try to do a backup,
and you realize your
backups are broken.
We do testing to ensure
you don't see that, right?
We also have an archiver.
And what this is doing is
it's mounting the drive,
it's tarballing up just
the raw binary MySQL files,
and then it's shipping those
off into cloud storage.
So we're shipping it
to GCS, and then we're
also shipping it
to S3 to ensure we
have a backup that's just
outside of our GCP account
domain.
So this is important
to us, because we
want to make sure
that if there's
a disaster we can recover, our
backups are sane, coherent,
we have copies
elsewhere, et cetera.
So we've put some time
and thought into this.
I also want to talk
about data warehousing.
So this is great.
We've solved backups,
we've solved replication,
and failover, et cetera.
But our data analysts,
they want this data.
There's a class of queries
that MySQL is really not
intended for, right?
Analytical queries, queries
over your entire data
set, large scans, et cetera.
So at the scale we're
talking about of a database
of several terabytes,
there's a lot of queries
that a scan over
the entire database
is going to take hours, right?
So we use BigQuery as
our data warehouse.
We really like BigQuery, and
we push both production data,
so the MySQL data, into
BigQuery, but also event data
we're streaming there.
And so to join these two data
sets, we need to do this copy.
So how do we do this?
This is a diagram
of this process.
Basically we've
written a go client,
and all this client does
is it's executed on a cron,
it's scanning through the
entire backup machine,
and it's streaming
this into a GCS file.
So what we end up with is a
group of files sitting in GCS,
I believe they're JSON
format, and this is
an entire copy of our database.
Once it's in GCS, it
becomes easy, right?
You press a button, and
you're able to import it
into BigQuery.
And BigQuery actually
handles the table swapping.
In other words, we have
a new copy of the data,
we're putting it on
BigQuery, and then
we need to swap it
in for the old table.
So BigQuery is
handling that for us.
So remember, this is a
totally separate system,
and this is executing on a
cron, so this is not up to date,
up to the minute.
It depends on the
table size, but we
run this, for some tables,
every day, and for some tables,
every week.
So there are separate systems,
and there is a delay there.
But it's a big win
because you're then
able to process the
MySQL data in BigQuery,
and you're able to join that
against our event data, which
is also sitting in BigQuery.
So we really like this.
We really like
this architecture.
BigQuery, and it's
been really powerful for us.
So as I mentioned, this
is kind of unfinished,
and there's a lot
of improvements.
We're always iterating on this.
And I just kind of want
to call out something
that we, internally,
at Quizlet think about
and want to improve.
So one is we want to improve
our scripting around failover.
There's a lot of
complexity here,
but quicker failover is better.
There are a few
things that we want
to do to increase the speed
with which we can do this.
And the other thing that we
see is that recovery sometimes
involves manual steps.
So if replication is off, if
the GTIDs are off, et cetera,
we've seen cases like that.
That sometimes
involves a developer
actually going and
looking at those,
and those we'd like to
narrow down on and eliminate.
Another thing that
we see is the larger
GCE instances, live
migration is not
totally transparent for systems
that are running really,
really heavy transactions.
And the effect of
this is effectively
your machine just kind
of drops for a second.
So you'll see-- there will
basically be a live migration
blackout, the machine will
disappear for a few seconds,
then it'll come back.
So this is pretty tricky.
You want to be able
to trust the VM.
We mitigate this by,
we watch for these.
So there's a notifier you can
watch that will tell you when
a live migration is coming.
But fundamentally, you need to
avoid single points of failure,
and you want to avoid relying
too much on a single machine.
As I said, the bigger machines
are more susceptible to this.
So the smaller machines
you can run, the better,
in a lot of cases.
A big problem with
our architecture
is we haven't
horizontally scaled yet.
So we're not doing
sharding of a single table
across multiple databases.
And we've done this
basically to be pragmatic.
There's a huge
amount of complexity
that comes with managing
sharding yourself.
There's a lot of solutions
in this space, as well.
And effectively we've been
able to punt this problem
and shard vertically,
rather than horizontally,
but it represents a pretty
fundamental limitation
on this architecture.
But one of the things
we're looking at
is what other technology
we can leverage.
As you saw, we have the
really strong growth rate.
And so our architecture is
going to continue to change,
and we're going to have
to adapt to the requests
from users coming in.
So we've been experimenting with
Cloud Spanner as a replacement
for MySQL in certain
places and an option
for continuing to scale this up.
And so actually, we
did a talk yesterday
about what we'd learned about
Cloud Spanner as a replacement
for some of this architecture,
and we have a blog post
about this, as well.
So it's also targeted at
if you're running a MySQL
architecture, and
you're figuring out
what the next step of that looks
like, it's intended for you.
So that's what I have.
I hope this was
useful and helpful,
and I think we're going
to take questions.
But if you don't get your
question [INAUDIBLE],
I'll be around, as well,
and happy to chat more
about this stuff.
[MUSIC PLAYING]